so so it's not obvious on first
consideration why disgust would be a
moral emotion so you know most of the
work that's done that's outside of the
disgust realm I would say is predicated
on the assumption that the reason that
conservatives in particular but perhaps
people who are more authoritarian in
general draw boundaries around their
territories because they're afraid of
the other but that isn't really that
isn't really how it plays out as far as
I can tell because conservatives for
example are less neurotic than trait in
the big five traits sense than liberals
although it's a it's a minor difference
but the disgust issue seems to be
particularly relevant so so can you tell
us a little bit about why disgust per se
well first conservatives are a little
less neurotic but they also at if you do
very low level perceptual experiment
just like a puff of white noise in the
ear people who react more strongly to
that to any sort of very low level
threat are more likely to vote
Republican in this country so there you
know there are all these interesting
personality differences that lead to
different politics but as for why
disgust so I'm I'm a durkheimian I would
say I love the the sociologist Emile
Durkheim and I'm also I'm a social
psychologist so I'm always thinking not
about people as individual utility
maximizers but people as members of
social groups people who are totally
focused on belonging in their social
groups and people who have some
pro-social motives about keeping the
group together about doing things that
are good for the group so as I try to
argue in my book the righteous mind
yes we're selfish there's no doubt that
we often will do things to advance our
own self-interest at the expense of
others but we're also really group
--is-- which means we'll do all sorts of
things to advance our group at the
expense of others basically we're tribal
we evolved as a tribal species and we're
doing we have all this software I would
say oh there's all these predispositions
these mental predispositions for life in
in tribes that are battling other tribes
and that's why it comes out so easily if
you look at the way boys organize
themselves when they get a fraternity
the hazing rituals when you look at the
way it's especially clear in boys
the way street gangs organized
themselves girls tribalism is a little
different but I would say this is and
that's why again I love the Union
approach of archetypes there's something
there's just this weird stuff that is
paying human even if it comes out
slightly differently around the world
there really is a human nature and it
comes complete with a whole bunch of
like pre-designed idea